et nous recevons ce matin le général
dominique trinquant bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes ancien
chef de la mission militaire française
aux nations unies l'invasion russe en
ukraine a débuté le 24 février depuis
des milliers de personnes sont mortes
des villes ukrainiennes ont été
détruites kiev n'a pas été prise
d'autres l'ont été la russie a changé de
stratégie militaire les troupes russes
ont quitté des villes de la banlieue de
kiev et se concentre désormais sur la
conquête de l'ensemble du dombass dans
l'est du pays tiers a été bombardé hier
en pleine visite d'antonio guterres est
ce le secrétaire général des nations
unies un immeuble a été touchée il y
aurait au moins une dizaine de blessés
comment est-ce qu'on peut interpréter ce
geste de l'awb l'armée russe en pleine
visite antonio guterres est ce encore
une fois eh bien écoutez j'ai connu
personnellement ça à sarajevo c'est à
dire que quand il ya des visites
importantes
il ya une frappe juste pour rappeler que
c'est la guerre et le secrétaire général
des nations unies arrivent en disant
qu'il est un artisan de paix qu'il veut
négocier on sait que son entretien
moscou s'est mal passé il en est sorti
en disant je ne peux rien faire et là il
est à kiev et donc les russes rappelle
qu effectivement les nations unies en
l'état des choses ne peuvent rien faire
parce que c'est la guerre et qu'il y
aura une solution armée
à cette guerre est ce que ça peut avoir
aussi un lien avec ces déclarations de
joe biden le président américain qui a
annoncé quelques heures auparavant
vouloir renforcer l'aide militaire à
l'ukraine il parle de 33 milliards dont
20 milliards pour cela fourniture
d'armement il veut également transférer
des avoirs russes saisie on le sait
également qu'il ya eu cette réunion dans
cette base avec différents pays
occidentaux il a été décidé de fournir
de l'armement plus lourd à l'ukraine
également ça s'est passé cette semaine
c'est un nouveau tournant dans le
conflit vladimir poutine ne supporte pas
oui je crois qu'il ya deux événements
importants pour
le dernier événement que vous citez
c'est à dire la réunion de rammstein
les alliés globalement mais y avait 40
pays donc ce n'est pas seulement le
temps les alliés prennent des mesures
rapides pour pouvoir fournir de
l'armement à l'ukraine pour se défendre
je reviendrai sur la situation un peu
plus tard il deuxième demande
effectivement c'est à washington on voit
bien que le président byden s'inscrit
dans la durée d'abord des fonds énormes
33 milliards une demande au congrès
puisqu'il ne peut plus avoir les fonds
exceptionnels dont ils pouvaient
bénéficier donc ils demandent l'unité
américaine autour de ce sujet et ça
c'est important et s'engager en dans la
durée parce que il ya non seulement de
l'armement mais aussi de pouvoir vivre
et de s'engager sur le long terme donc
on voit bien qu'on a un tournant où on
règle les problèmes immédiats mais on se
projette dans l'avenir parce que cette
guerre va durer joe biden a d'ailleurs
dit ah vous n'aurez jamais le cren mais
il dit bien que c'est pour aider le cren
et non pas pour attaquer la russie on va
revenir notre notamment sur ses
déclarations côté russe en début de
semaine sergueï lavrov le chef de la
diplomatie russe parler et brandissait
la menace d'une troisième guerre
mondiale
mercredi c'est vladimir poutine qui
s'est exprimé devant le parlement qui
était d'ailleurs pour l'occasion
délocalisé à saint pétersbourg qui est
son fief il a bien dit il a mis en garde
contre toute intervention extérieure en
ukraine il a promis que l'arrêt pas la
riposte serait rapide et foudroyante
qu'est-ce qu'il faut encore voir dans
cette déclaration encore dans cette
danse nouvelle menace brandie par le
président russe bien lorsqu'il faut voir
deux choses la première chose c'est que
là le président poutine est sous
pression il veut obtenir quelque chose
pour le neuf oui alors le 9 mai on le
rappelle c'est le jour de la victoire la
victoire sur les nazis voilà la vie
quand on revient sur les nazis la grande
guerre patriotique
or c'est important puisque le président
poutine prétend qu'il combat contre les
nazis en ukraine donc le rappel est
évident et au passage les répétitions
pour le défilé à pied ont commencé sur
la place rouge ce matin donc on voit
bien que ça se prépare donc il s'est mis
lui même sous la pression d'une certaine
façon le président poutine et il a
besoin de
marquer sa détermination et sa volonté
de continuer cette guerre deuxième point
le président biden a été beaucoup plus
près
prudent pardon que son ministre de la
défense secrétaire d'état qui a annoncé
à ramstein qu'il était là pour affaiblir
l'armée pour affaiblir la russie or ça
permettez moi de vous dire c'est
extrêmement dangereux de dire ça même
s'il sait la réalité peu importe on
n'est pas obligé de le dire on est là
pour soutirer encore bien sûr on est là
pour
soutenir l'ukraine dire qu'on va
affaiblir la russie ça va être
immédiatement récupéré par la propagande
russe en disant vous voyez bien on est
en troisième guerre mondiale puisque
c'est la russie contre les états unis
donc il faut éliminer ce sujet là et
bien soutenir la position de droit dans
laquelle nous sommes charte des nations
unies article 51 un pays est attaqué il
a le droit de se défendre et nous avons
le droit de l'aider donc c'est dans ce
cadre là qu'on doit se placer la défense
d'un pays qui est agressée et non pas là
la
défaite du pays agresseur qui est un
autre sujet c'est important de le
rappeler d'ailleurs par rapport à
l'ukraine au fait que tous ces pays
occidentaux être l'ukraine en lui
fournissant notamment des armes est ce
que le fait de fournir ces armes à
l'ukraine est ce que ça peut permettre
de renverser la tendance
écoutez premier point
l'armement met du temps à arriver alors
vous avez trois types d'armements
l'armement que les ukrainiens saisissent
auprès de l'armée russe c'est la
majorité les sharks auraient bien sûr
abandonner l aimer ton 200 250 chats
c'est la totalité des chars de l'armée
française voyez pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur donc la russie jusqu'à
maintenant est le premier fournisseur
d'armements à l'ukraine et on y brad
hawpe seul en r c'est paradoxalement
c'est paradoxal mais faut le rappeler et
ça a un avantage majeur c'est que les
ukrainiens peuvent s'en servir tout de
suite parce qu'ils le connaissent il est
sur le terrain ils le connaissent il ya
un problème de munitions dans lequel je
rentrerai pas je ne sais pas quelle est
la dotation en munitions qui a été prise
avec ça c'est le première dotation la
deuxième dotation c'est les armements
qui ont été fournis depuis quinze jours
à peu près par les pays anciennement du
pacte de varsovie les pays d'europe de
l'est qui ont de l'armement similaire à
ce qu'elle ukraine là aussi c'est
d'armement qui peut tout de suite être
utilisés qui peut être livrés et puis
l'armement que nous livrons les
américains les français les britanniques
etc hélas et de l'armement de chez nous
je vais dire occidentale et donc là il
faut former le personnel parce que les
ukrainiens ne connaissent pas il faut
acheminer et il faut mettre en oeuvre
tout ça et ça ça prend un peu de temps
c'est pour ça que l'offensive
aujourd'hui sur le terrain des russes à
un double croco chronomètre le 9 mai
dont j'ai déjà parlé mais aussi
l'arrivée de ces équipements il faut que
les russes remportent
une victoire qui les arrive à enfoncer
ou à contourner les forces l'ukrainienne
avant que ces renforcements n'arrive et
ne peuvent se faire basculer le rapport
de force en faveur des ukrainiens donc
je crois qu'aujourd'hui les ukrainiens
ont les moyens de freiner d'arrêter
l'armée russe les renforcements pourrait
faire basculer mais il ya un problème de
chronomètre que je ne maîtrise pas est
ce que le fait de vouloir conquérir la
totalité du thon basse et du sud de
l'ukraine est ce que c'est vraiment
réalisable du coup dans ces conditions
là alors je pense que là les russes ont
fait quelque chose qu'il faut que nous
nous rappelions
j'étais je travaillais sur ses plans
avant la chute du mur de berlin
la russie a attaqué sur tout le front de
kiev au donbass à la crimée elle a
échoué sur trois des fronts elle a
décidé de retirer tous ses moyens et de
les concentrer salavert le seul endroit
où il y avait eu des gains souvenons
nous entre la crimée le dombass mario
paul et donc elle concentre ses moyens
là elle donne le commandement à un seul
général qui commande là donc
concentration des efforts unité de
commandement et là elles consentent 82
bataillon donc elles frappent depuis une
semaine avec l'artillerie avec les
avions pour entamer la défense
ukrainienne qui est très solide
puisqu'elle était face au donbass depuis
2004 14 1 et donc elle frappe est là
elle commence à avancer alors
aujourd'hui ça ne se voit pas trop mais
là des gains puis il ya beaucoup de
combats de rue des
petits villages qui sont gagnés mais ça
veut dire que la russie progressent
beaucoup plus précautionneusement avec
des axes dans lequel il ya des appuis
réciproque c'est à dire que un axe peu
appuyé l'autre et c'est donc avec
beaucoup de précaution elle est obligée
de le faire si elle veut avoir une
victoire est obligé de le faire parce
que les forces russes quand même qu'on
bat depuis deux mois donc sont un peu et
trier mais elle peut bénéficier parfois
en particulier dans la région du zoom au
nord du contournement des forces
ukrainienne donc on va le voir à mon
avis dans la semaine qui vient on à la
vérité sur le terrain une dernier quart
des questions très rapidement est ce que
vous pensez que la dioxine votre jour
conquérir finalement l'ensemble de
l'ukraine non il ne peut plus il ne peut
plus il a raté ça il ya deux mois il ne
peut plus ce qu'il veut c'est conquérir
territorialement pour pouvoir dire vous
voyez j'ai libéré puisque c'est le terme
qu'il emploie j'ai libéré le dombass
enfin nous avons nos frères qui peuvent
venir chez nous et à partir de là est en
mesure de négocier mais maintenant sur
le long terme il faut voir que nous
sommes dans une guerre idéologique avec
la russie aujourd'hui donc ça ne va pas
s'arrêter là et c'est pour ça que
l'engagement sur le long terme
américains est important et l'engagement
des européens dans tous les domaines
économiques armement psychologique était
extrêmement important merci mon général
d'avoir répondu à toutes ses questions
et d'avoir été avec lui ce matin